This seems bad.
It's not amazing.
Why would PETA use this shot?
This wasn't even during
the photo shoot.
This was taken during
my peanut butter break.
You're the one who wanted
to pose naked
and pretend it was
for a good cause
so you wouldn't look
like a whore even though
that's secretly why
everybody does it.
Can you fix it?
Of course.
It's my job.
What about doing some
appearances
for Operation Smile?
What is that?
The organization that fixes
cleft palates.
No, I really don't want
to deal with paint.
Ugh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, wait.
What about pity (bleep)
a prom loser?
Yes, that's it, right?
All the hot celebrities
are doing that now.
Yeah, I don't think
any of them are actually
having sex with the teenagers,
but I don't think that going
to prom is a terrible idea.
Did a student ask you?
No.
Not yet.
But I bet if I just Google it,
he's out there somewhere.
Yeah.
You just make sure
the press is there.
Oh, I will.
Okay.
Will you bring this with you?
Sure.
Unless you think it's okay.
I--I don't.
Okay.
Prom.
God.
Ugh.
Who do we have here?
That's why if you're
watching this,
I really hope you agree
to come to prom with me.
I promise we'll have
a really great time.
Please say yes.
Love, Lucas.
You just got yourself
a prom date, buddy.
♪
Wait, he's still in
high school.
Well, I hope this kid's ready
to eat (bleep) a ton of (bleep).
Wait here until
after the dance, Montgomery.
Yes, ma'am!
♪
♪ My milkshake brings
all the boys to the yard ♪
♪ And they're like
it's better than yours ♪
♪ Damn right,
♪ I can teach you,
but I have to charge ♪
♪ My milkshake brings
all the boys to the yard ♪
♪ And they're like
it's better than yours ♪
♪ Damn right,
♪ I can teach you ♪
♪
Excuse me, ma'am, the Al-Anon
meeting is on Sunday.
No, you silly hooker,
I'm here for the prom!
L-L-L-L-Lucas!
Hi.
Hi, do I know you?
I'm your celebrity prom date.
I'm Amy Schumer.
Surprised?
Uh, I've never heard of you.
You know, "When's lunch?"
Uh, this is my girlfriend
Madison.
Girlfriend?
What about your YouTube video?
Oh, you mean the one where
I asked Madison to prom?
Did you even watch
the whole thing?
Is anybody (bleep)
talking to you, Madison?
This is none of your business.
You seriously need
to back off right now.
Excuse me,
this is my business.
Oh, really?
You know what?
You're ruining the best night
of Lucas' short life, okay?
Whatever, Joy Behar.
What?
Get off of--
You get off!
This is-- Ow!
Oh, my God,
you killed him!
Let go!
My God!
I'm a cripple!
You give it back,
I brought that!
Out of my way!
These are the best years
of your lives
because you're (bleep) losers!
You think you could
follow Tosh?
You can't, I was Variety's
top ten comics to watch 2009!
Montgomery,
I'm riding up front!
Whatever you say,
Mrs. S!
Oh, my God.
My arms look so skinny.
They do.
They really do.